[Music]
growing up i was always the littlest guy
on my team
even now i think i still am
[Music]
you don't listen to what anybody says
you can't do
because you know that you can
[Music]
you ready
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
being able to shoot all about becoming a
more complete and confident ball handler
pulling out a dribbling clinic to
maximize the quickest release possible
for you
lock in on the path that the ball takes
from your catch-ready position
to your final release point so that's
how you can shoot the same from whether
it's in the paint
all the way out to the d3 area and knock
it down
when you catch and you're ready to shoot
i look where the rim and the net meet
put that basketball right on those hooks
and that's what i lock in on
[Music]
curry splits the defense behind the back
fires the three
oh it cuts in stop it right there
everyone
my defender has clearly established his
lead foot
make him open his whole body and create
a driving angle
i have all the control all the leverage
in the world right here look at ian
travel though
good gracious
[Music]
we overload ourselves in the workout
with two basketballs or a tennis ball
makes the game seem a lot slower and
you're able to process things a lot
better
ah that's why we're here to get better
it might be tough you might have to
overcome a lot more than the guy next to
you but that's what makes it all worth
it
no matter where you are in your
progression we're all in the same boat
i'm still searching for perfection and
their full potential in this game
the time is now for you to start your
journey to find ways to get better
that's why we're all here you need to
get in the gym and get to work
time's ticking i'm stephen curry
and this is my master class
you